let's talk about how to choose your proteins
wisely now the problem with protein is that
in nature protein never comes as a complete
protein it comes with fat and there's such a
thing called the insulin index which looks at the
protein effect of insulin so in other words the
leaner the protein the more the spike in insulin
if you want to get into ketosis very very deeply
you don't want to do the lean protein you want
to do more fatty or protein now if we look at
the ketogenic diet as far as a pie chart
five percent should be carbs and i failed
to also add another five percent for salad and
vegetables because i don't count those into the
equation so roughly 10 carbs but half of that
should be vegetable and 20 protein and then we
have 70 fat so we're just going to focus on the
fat the protein right now so if we look at 70 fat
to 20 protein we're looking at the percentage of
calories and you can see wow that's a lot of fat
to protein right it's actually three and a half
times more fat than protein but if we take a look
at the actual weight in grams simply because
there's more uh condensed energy in fat than
protein then we're dealing with a different ratio
we're dealing with 1.56 to one ratios so we're
talking about weight okay because when people say
wow you're eating this high fat diet you're eating
70 of your calories fat it's really kind of like
a a little more than a one to one ratio so when
you really look at it from a weight point of
view it doesn't look that unreasonable okay
so the more that we can align ourselves with this
ratio right here the more truly keto it is now
if we increase this even more we have more
fat to protein then we're going to generate
more ketones and this is what they do for
epileptic children the diet is very very
high in fat because they're trying to generate
enough ketones from the fat to really make it work
and when you have more fat to protein it's really
good on your digestive system it's a lot better
than doing leaner proteins and of course that
depends on what type of fat you're talking about
but what happens too is when you increase
more fat you increase more stimulation of
bile from your liver to actually digest the fat
people who are on a low fat diet end up with
a deficiency of bile and they're more at risk
for getting gallstones which is interesting
all right let's take a look at this chart right
here it's very very interesting so we have fat
and protein we're just looking at kind of the
ratios here an egg is the one to one ratio
so if you're eating egg maybe you add a little
more fat to that um you could do it several
ways you could add a little butter or whatever
hamburger two to one that's a pretty good ratio
twice as much fat as protein so hamburger is
a really good thing to do for keto i consume
a lot of hamburger steak look at this one to two
wow most steak that you eat is just not fatty
enough and people tend to cut off the fat they
don't eat the fat so if you're gonna do a steak
maybe make sure you add more fat to that meal
all right chicken actually it's lower in fat
higher in protein so there's twice as much protein
as fat but i'm not sure about this one because
here's the point if you're eating this with the
skin with where there's some fat underneath it
this might even out to a 1.1 uh ratio so always
eat the skin on on the chicken all right bacon one
to one now you would think it'd be a lot higher
in fat it is but you're frying off all the fat so
if you're doing bacon you want to actually add
some more fat to the meal okay look at this a
pecan seven to one pecan is very very fatty
of course we're not talking about saturated
fats we're talking about omega-6 fatty acid and
there's a little bit of carb okay there's a tiny
bit of carb but pecans are a really good nut to
consume i consume pecans probably on a daily basis
this is a good ratio all right now let's talk
about the peanut it's two to one it's good ratio
but many times if i eat a meal i will have some
peanut butter with celery just to get a little
bit more fat in the diet all right cod liver now
i'm not talking about cod liver oil talk about
cod liver it's right here check this out icelandic
cod liver maybe you've never heard about it before
there's many different brands most of them are
wild caught okay so that's the one you want to get
i don't know if they get it all from the same
place but this is quite good look at the ratio
five times as much fat to protein this is
definitely ketogenic food and the oil in it
actually is all from the cod liver okay so i'm not
saying you're gonna drink the whole thing uh you
could and maybe you should you can actually put
it in the refrigerator and have a little bit each
day but yesterday i consumed an entire can it was
a little too much fat in one sitting but if you
did a half of this you'd be great but yesterday
i was not hungry for the entire day i think i
just had one meal and normally i'll have two but
this is extremely satisfying summer sausage now
what is summer sausage it's a type of sausage
here's an example that you normally don't need
to refrigerate it unless you open it up and then
you put in the refrigerator this one it says to
refrigerate okay that's cool but this is something
that i consume on a regular basis as well of
course this one is organic uncured summer sausage
the problem is trying to find summer sausage
without dextrose which is synthetic sugar and
without nitrates now this does have celery juice
and i did a video on this topic it's true that
celery juice does have nitrates and so therefore
people say well it's the same as the nitrates you
would get from other sources right but there's
really no studies that i could find that said that
consuming celery juice with the nitrates has any
harmful effects so it may create some harmful
effects but if you know of a study put it down
below but i'm still alive i've been consuming this
for a long time so this has organic beef sea salt
all right and then it has organic honey
now i know what you're going to say
you said not to have honey this is a very very
small amount i'm okay with it it's like one
gram per serving so it's pretty low and then we
have organic spices cultured celery juice powder
lactic acid starter culture but this is like a
two to one ratio so it's it's actually perfect
if i'm in a hurry i can just chop this off i
might add some cheese to it i might just have
it by itself and i'm good to go and also lucy
our little granddaughter who's two right now
loves this and it's it's pretty healthy
and i know someone is going to want to know
where do i get this you're going to have to
look it up i have no affiliation with these
companies um but i will put a link down below of
of the names of these so you can do the research
on them okay then we get to the macadamia nut
look at this 11.5 fat to a one protein ratio
this is quite killer nut in a good way
all right sardines now check this out
here's an example of some sardines you would
think it'd be fattier but look at it has twice
as much protein as fat but it comes in oil
so a lot of that oil is going to shift this
is probably going to be like a one to one ratio
so this is i consume sardines it's totally fine
you need to do it but look at this
salmon 1.5 to 1. so apparently salmon
fits this closest it's the ideal keto food i
love salmon i love fatty fish i consume salmon
on a regular basis salmon also has selenium to
counter any potential mercury that's in that
fish but of course you want to do wild caught all
right in summary if you want to get into a little
deeper ketosis focus more on the proteins
that are higher in fat thanks for watching
hey before you go real quick i have a course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune system
it's a free course i want you to take it and
here's why here's you here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over
here avoiding your environment but
what about here what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and resist
your environment much better by strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today